is my name Greg Alba
you betcha you betcha you live here
you'd be home by day oh yeah this is
John Humphrey John of the real rejects
the rejects
so I have no really TV spots you know I
kind of just don't really care to watch
them I don't get to watch TV know the
concept like the the size of a TV spot
just doesn't fit my brain anymore you
know but after a while you know when you
get so many requests from different
social media platforms to go you got to
watch the Thor Ragnarok extended tdys
contenders you're like all right you
know what you got to make people happy
because life is about satisfying people
that are not you yeah that is the key to
happiness friends and I hope Thor learns
that lesson in Thor Ragnarok by the way
shout out of the day patreon gotta go to
totally jumbled stay tuned i'm aaron
miles bro Matt Lyles totally jump you'll
get another video but no you're mine
discuss a message on patreon replied
back to it please
tennis
[Music]
whoa
the revenge's
[Music]
it's funny how we saw that the thor
ragnarok toon sandwich video the trailer
spoof yeah and at the end they were
talking about the name bit yeah and I
don't even know if they saw in fact they
saw like that moment yeah from a trailer
or if they just promoting that I don't
know but that's because that's the first
time I saw that moment yeah I was
reading an interview with Tiki watts
dinky Watts what we do in the show's TV
was boy I've never heard TV Watson
yeah I was gonna interview with him I
have a way I wanna meet Tiki one day he
white well you might thought okay was we
any interview with him and he was saying
he you know one thing that this movie's
gonna be is like he wanted to make sure
Thor was the most badass character in it
he wanted to make sure Thor was the main
character that you like walks away from
like that was the most badass one but he
said a lot of really cool things that I
thought as a directors aspiration were
really awesome to this let's see what TT
go iet says complicated ask me where's
he from
geez I'm like Brendan Jermaine another
thing too is that he was making like an
insomnia for from seeing this trailer
you know like they're talking about
putting together a team contenders I
know this gets a lot of jokes for being
like trying to be like guardians of the
galaxy but the more I read about it and
then we're footage I see I don't feel
like it's gonna try to be guardians of
the galaxy I like the idea of having a
team inside of Thor's world as well cuz
what's the one thing that it's a great
thing about all comic book characters is
that they're all there's a whole
universe inside of each comic book
character yeah and so when you when you
go into somebody's solo world there's so
much yeah they're gonna be in here there
could be a team just within there
you know I'm excited to see that aspect
of it the team looks really badass any
another thing he says he loves his
actors improvise a lot yeah and you can
feel that like it the way the diet all
the chicken making is you laugh in the
trailers I'm like that's all in here you
know you see that even though Mike the
line about you know you should have team
name and stuff oh my god bet it has some
of that supervisor right there he was
like I can't really look back on the
first two Thor movies I like them but I
can't really look back I just want to
make my own thing because I'm gonna be
able to do another one of these ever so
I'm just gonna make my own thing so the
more I've read about this the more
excited I've gotten for it tickets
hurting on presale haven't got tickets
yet working on that the more I see from
it the more I want to see it yeah you
love this director what we do in the
shadows is like one of your all-time
faves
yeah and that was like that was one of
the quickest you know like it takes a
long time sometimes to figure out how
much you love a movie or not but that
was a movie like from the very first
time I saw it I'm like this is amazing
yeah this is great the fact that you got
to do this and also like I know it can
be treacherous territory because some of
my favorite directors have not clashed
yeah next well with marble it seems like
it's working out and he's getting to do
what he wants to do are you talking
about Karen Fukunaga on it yes usually
yeah we kind of don't we skip over TV
spots and stuff but this actually seemed
like I had new images spilling it like a
like an event fight you know like coming
off McGregor and Mayweather Thorin and
Hulk - and Hulk yeah go bloom I really
feel like we're in for a surprise with
Jeff Goldblum in this movie I feel like
were taking a lot of time to talk with
Jeff Goldblum you know like take te
Kawai he was saying I wrote it it's
easier to perceive it teeka Thai Thai
taike
times that should be a why i kawaii t
ytt taiko y TT
I don't like to be the guy really change
your name but damn man change your name
Taika Waititi this is going swimming
whatever [ __ ] I forgot I'm excited for
Thor daughters Raya what's your name
lost my train of thought hey shout out
time that's right format Lyles
the man who we shout out every month
never talks to us on patreon even when
we tried I think he like left a comment
after the last time I said this but it
was like so brief like yeah you need to
get back you need to get better at
replying in the back I'm just observing
you know enjoying the ambiance and yeah
good
you know poke your head in say hey you
say I kind of snow your a lot do you
even watch anything we post on patreon
it's a Matthew other day we've had over
a hundred thirty exclusive posts on
patreon it's combination of like videos
and like deleted takes and pictures and
stuff so yeah there's like plenty of
things on patreon I'm like I never got
one feedback from this guy pledging for
the shout out here every single month
which comes all that stuff I'm talking
about maybe it's just the exclusive
pictures yeah
just made me laugh this is actually the
origin story to a tale in a movie where
a guy is lazy and fat no but he has to
be kind of a hero by the end of it
alright guys well thanks for tuning in
make sure to go watch Thor Ragnarok this
is all a paid video we Marvel yeah
Marvel pays us for every single tomatoes
but they do
and and Warner Brothers who owns Rotten
Tomatoes also pays us to hate on DC
Mayor secretly Batman V Superman was
like our third favorite movie it really
was yeah subscribe to the real rejects
you know you can do - you can click
bells from here on out I want you to go
to dad John Humphrey on Twitter in his
crib become a patron Oh jack today ask
your doctor or your sister
[Music]